welcome back it's time for our Friday
Follies segment we have some fantastic
stories to share with you but first some
news Democrats are launching a religious
war over the departure of a House
chaplain I'm glad the Democrats know
there is a House chaplain Fox News
contributor Raymond Arroyo will Wilder
series author has some exclusive details
Raymond what is going on this is a
firestorm that was breaking out it
should have been a very small story it
was on it was first announced father Pat
Conroy has been the chaplain for a
number of years he was the second
Catholic chaplain but the first one how
they're dismissed for the House of
Representatives but here's the deal he
apparently gave a prayer before the tax
vote and some thought there was a little
partisan intent there now Democrats are
saying he was removed by Paul Ryan
because of the prayer this is what they
said today they stormed the floor
demanding not only an investigation but
more watch dismissal of father Conroy
following this prayer shows Republicans
true refusal to embody the values of
faith and charity in the legislative
work resolved that there is hereby
established they select committee to
investigate the actions and motivations
behind the resignation of the House
chaplain they basically want a special
counsel against Paul Ryan for Nancy
Pelosi says it's unjust I've spoken to a
number of members today in you you
arraignment was on the phone with four
members of Congress one Democrats three
Republicans what'd you find here's what
they told me some of them complained to
Paul Ryan himself one told me father was
a little bit more partisan than pastor
others said they went to him for
counseling and thought he wasn't as warm
or understanding as he should have been
they went to the Senate chaplain instead
and they complained to Paul Ryan it was
the I think accumulation of this stuff
including pushing and lobbying for
certain bills an edge of partisanship
that they didn't like that's what led to
his dismissal it seems and I've gotten
that from very high officials you know
right so this is a tempest and well look
the Republicans are doing themselves no
favors now representative mark Walker
has been appointed to a committee to
find a new chaplain he said he wants a
man who has a family and children
that's Santa let me tell you something
parish please have a family it's their
whole it's welfare and the Eastern Rite
priests and deacons their marriage I
don't like that comment Facebook
censored free speech diamond and silk
now diamond and silk took Capitol Hill
this week we did not get to this the
other way do we have a clue yet watch
let's watch this is classic watch you
all have been bashing Facebook and
you've been making a ton of money in
that correct Facebook no no we didn't
bash Facebook how Facebook has been
conservative voices like ourselves
Facebook sister our free speech and
shame on the ones that don't even see
that we have been censored if the shoe
was on the other foot and Mark
Zuckerberg was a conservative and we
were liberals oh oh Fitz's and all
chains would have broke loose you know
it and I know it mmm I'll tell you Tyler
Perry should sign my man in silk goes to
Washington this is a miniseries
I was dreaming laughing they wouldn't
even let them get a question in every
time they saw that's okay there's a big
story the night but an hour I they fall
a story people are paying yes for
cuddles yes there is a there is a
therapy if you don't get enough human
touch that with video of this these
people this is a group
I don't it's a website person not to
cuddle cuddle list there are cuddles
hundred professional cuddlers now just
bear in mind we have a growing a number
of people who are single without spouses
up 2/3 42% now I'm commuting the host of
this and now they claim because of that
more people than ever they're even
having cuddling parties here in
Washington DC because people are so
upset after the election they're scared
they want
you know how much they're charging how
much $80 and oh what is the cuddling and
here let me read this to you
Washington knows you lean against the
provider hold hands or a spoon while you
talk
it's non-sexual touch it's just
affirming and they say it's therapeutic
and it relaxes you so Lori box well I've
done the math I'm not going to cuddle
with you but I will give you a hug for a
buck 30 it's time get away from me no
way this is really a sign of the decline
of the cuddling with my favorite is a
dying party they are all together rather
go to a Tupperware party than a cuddling
party and the people I was watching I
don't want to cuddle with anybody but my
wife people cuddling like ixnay I'm not
gonna cuddle with you they look like
they really should have a bath
certificate but no bathing zone yeah god
bless them Oh shucks we didn't go to
Nancy Pelosi shaming us on our next time
next time good weekend don't ever ever
think of cuddling here